[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça ne sa découvre
la Réunion ensemble vous allez paraît
alors allons-nous
[Musique]
comment il
est parle pas moins les misérables alors
au samedi toujours à silaos sur la route
départementale des 242 alors sinon
gardien ici hop ici d242 et ben nous va
aller jusqu'à la cascade Bras Rouge
cascade Bras Rouge par là allez
allons-nous comment
[Musique]
bonjour messieurs dames bonjour monsieur
comment ça va bonjour madame vous
revenez d'où comme ça là on vient de la
casquette du Bras Rouge d'accord
et c'est une randonnée facile alors
ça se plutôt bien et au niveau de la
remontée franchement je suis
agréablement surprise donc c'est c'est
magnifique il y a pas d'autre
et pourquoi vous avez décidé de devenir
fait cette randola aujourd'hui on a une
amie qui réunionnaise mes parents sont
venus 5 fois et ils ont adoré et
franchement c'est notre première fois et
on sait très bien que ce sera pas la
dernière on reviendra en 2023 ça c'est
sûr on a fait le Costa Rica et
franchement
on préfère largement la Réunion
la diversité des paysages enfin je sais
pas moi je trouve que ça nous prend au
triple il y a quelque chose enfin moi je
suis accueille aussi c'est vrai
je prends le terme réunion
votre pays est magnifique
[Musique]
bonjour comment on est là et bien
on fait une petite pause devant un petit
peu d'eau là bien rafraîchissant après
une petite marche
de cascade
la pointe ça manque un peu par rapport à
ce stress qu'on met un peu partout
[Musique]
c'est le plus dur la fait
non il y a peut-être 5 minutes 5 minutes
oui les chiens oui oui 5 minutes merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
ben voilà au bout de 45 minutes nous
arrive à la fameuse cascade il est là en
tout cas les vrais mon impressionnants
et les vraiment jolie faut faire très
attention parce que Nana le robot et
peut être très dangereux et ben nous ça
nous a fait nous va remonter et ben nous
on va aller visite les termes de Cilaos
allez allons-nous
mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène parle pas nous aller nous verrez
la même appelle respect pour mon pays
vraiment d'après depuis son lit au-delà
de mon pays la réunion nous les la même
mais mon pays comment il est la Réunion
bah voilà nouvelle visite le terme de
silence
bonjour monsieur bonjour ça va bien ça
va bon est-ce que vous êtes un petit peu
conseil un peu l'histoire de
l'établissement là alors ici nous sommes
donc au terme de Cilaos d'accord fait
partie des établissements thermal qui
fait partie du département nous avons
deux casquettes nous avons des cures
thermales médicales et nous faisons
aussi
des prestations de bien-être pour tout
le public donc pour le médical c'est
pour des problèmes d'hématologiques et
digestifs donc des cours de 3 semaines
sur prescription médicale et
l'après-midi ben c'est pour tous ceux
qui sont en vacances pour faire profiter
les Réunionnais des installations
thermales mais aussi de l'installation
de bien-être comme le hammam sauna le
week-end et les après-midis d'accord et
en quoi les eaux les autres thermales de
Cilaos les les particuliers
elle est exceptionnelle cette eau là
c'est vraiment vraiment c'est le
patrimoine de la Réunion ça allait
exceptionnel elle est riche en fer elle
est riche en minéraux elle est carbo
gazeuse bicarbonate elle est en Belgique
anti-inflammatoire on a des formules
formules randonnée formule formule du
sportif par exemple on fait Piton des
Neiges on vient ici on vient faire des
temps des massages des bains et ça
détend et du coup est-ce que Mobilia
allait visiter moi bah vas-y tu peux y
aller les équipes elles t'attendre elles
sont formidables elles vont s'attendre
bonjour madame bonjour monsieur comment
il est eh ça va bien ça va bon dis-moi
que ça fait trois semaines que je suis
là et que ça se passe bien
ça me remet en forme les vrais je
retrouve ma troisième jeunesse c'est
excellent et qui ça la conseille de
Nutella mais ça fait plusieurs années
que je viens par ici au moins 45 ans et
est-ce qu'il y a maintenant
j'ai 83 ans et je me sens jeune quoi
quel genre de soin aux filles ici là
mais ici il y a trois soins par jour
il y a le bain c'est sûr tous les jours
il y a le kiné aussi sous mes kinés qui
massage sous l'eau
et puis il y a le G aussi d'accord qu'on
apprécie et puis il y a le cataplasme
[Musique]
vraiment en plus soleil il pète on a
fini par les terminus Laos oublie pas
c'est le seul établissement tu as mal de
l'océan Indien ok la Réunion Gaia allons
prendre le temps visite et pour ça on
vous a un prochain épisode de l'émission
à l'ONU la saison il a fini rendez-vous
la saison 2 derrière la semaine à vous
[Musique]
allons nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]